head coach of the Chicago Bears by way
of the New York dragons I think he's the
only coach in the league who has had
time with the New York dragons Carolina
Cobras Georgia force and Columbus
destroyers of the AFL making his way
through the ante read coaching tree all
the way to the sidelines of the Chicago
Bears head coach Matt Negi here on the
program how are you coach Goodrich how
you doing are you the only one with that
resume in the innocent I think so it
sounds it's pretty crazy but yeah that
was a fun little league to play in and
but I like this league now short how
much how much of the Arena League have
you brought into your scheme a little
bit here know what it's it's it's been a
decent amount not much the biggest thing
for that I tell people with the Arena
League is really at the quarterback
position is the anticipatory throws or
the anticipation throws you know for for
those guys as you can kind of relate as
when when you're when you're talking to
these guys you can tell them hey listen
if they're running on a post route or a
corner route you try to anticipate the
throw tight windows in the Arena League
and so it's more specific to the
position than it would be by concepts
well I'm sure you studied a whole ton of
true Biscay film before taking this job
what was the attribute that you saw on
film about this kid that made you think
you know what I can work with that so
with with Mitch when I was in Kansas
City we went through an expensive
process of evaluating the quarterback
position we brought in six guys in that
draft from two years ago
coach Reed myself and Brad Childress and
we spent about six hours with all six
guys and Mitch obviously being one of
those guys and so when we when we were
with them at the combine you only get 15
minutes and and you know you can't you
can't there's just not enough time to
know who that person is and how they
work one-on-one and so when we brought
Mitch in we were able to to kind of
really get a good feel who he was and so
I had the advantage knowing that coming
into this job with the Bears and knowing
who he was as a person and how he you
know where his his football IQ was as a
quarterback and so you know the biggest
question with him coming out was his
lack of experience at North Carolina and
but but from going through our offense
with him on the board and knowing where
he was at we we left
that meaning extremely impressed by omen
so I knew right away that that helped me
and knowing who he was and then the more
I got to spend time with him here in
OTAs and then obviously in the training
camp he's everything that we thought he
was and I'm just really looking forward
to the future
so then what what is the future how
bright isn't what do you go I think it's
bright I really do I think that he's a
first of all he's a kid that at this
position you want to have we talk about
guys being obsessed and and in the right
way and so he this guy's just he's a
complete football junkie he wants to be
the best and he's gonna do everything he
possibly can to make sure that he's
preparing as much as he can and so you
know this offense does take a little bit
of time and and for him there's a lot to
it there's a lot of different things we
put a lot of pressure on the quarterback
to make the right decisions and choices
and what I had to do rich was I have to
be able to you know five years in in one
system with with Alex Smith and with
coach Reid
we were able to really evolve in that
system and we got really advanced I had
I learned it here now as a play caller
you know slash head coach dealing with
with Mitch and these other quarterbacks
is that I need to train myself to pull
back it's not fair to try to think that
we're going to be in year five of where
we were at Kansas City so what we've
done is we've gone back to the quote
unquote meat and potatoes of the offense
and and tried to see what fits him and
the rest of the guys and so it's taken a
little bit of time we finally clicked it
together for a game this past weekend
and it was it was nice for those guys to
see what what what could happen
Madden Aggie Bears head coach here on
the Rich Eisen show and I know you've
got your own shop to take care of but
you did just mention again how you were
first introduced to true Biscay being
part of the chief staff that went ahead
and drafted Patrick mahomes I assume you
saw last night I am a Monday Night
Football are you surprised at how well
he is playing out of the chute in just
four games as the starter this year no
not at all I you know it's a you know it
to start he's under one of the best in
the league to do that and to teach
quarterbacks in in coach read and and he
knows that he understands that he's got
a great staff around him he's got
excellent players and so Patrick has the
mind
of of you know just trying to learn as
much as he can
he had a great benefit of learning this
offense through Alex Smith as well last
year which which was it was huge for him
and so now what he's done he's been
given an opportunity he's got all the
talent in the world he can make tons of
great plays as you saw last night none
of that was shocking to me at all spent
in a full year with him knowing what he
can do I mean he's very comfortable
outside of the pocket and he can ad-lib
and make things happen with his arm and
his legs and so that's not something
that that there's that stuff that you
saw last night
in that game that stuff that he does in
practice so that's not anything that
just breaks out during the game and and
so I'm happy for him I'm happy for Coach
read to everybody there on that staff
and I thought it was a great win for
them the taking of the ball in the right
hand putting into the left hand shoving
it up is that something gonna put cut up
and put on film for two Biscay to put in
his game ya know that's one of those
deals where you know it just kind of
naturally happens I think the last one I
remember seeing is Eli do that a few
years ago and so you know hey Mitch has
that in his repertoire I know he does
he's a pretty athletic kid that uh you
know he kid he played shortstop and in
high school and I know that it has it in
him but he'll hola
I guess maybe break it out when need be
yes before we return to your current
shop if you don't mind turning you into
analyst for a second more coach Matt
naggy I couldn't help but notice that
Andy Reid is just sitting next to
mahomes when the defense is on the field
what what is he telling him best you
know read and well system so typically
what's happening there is his coach is
going to go through and just kind of get
a feel for number one which is what just
occurred in that previous possession and
clear that up and that's pretty quick
the next part is now coaches prepping
for for the next series and he wants to
kind of he has an idea of what he likes
as a play caller and and what he's
feeling and I think it's more of not a
quiz but he wants to ask his quarterback
he'll ask Patrick you know hey do you
like this play do you like that play and
and most quarterbacks will tell you they
like them all but he'll give you you
know the answers that eat that he likes
and then and then if it's you know you
get a feel by their answer the way they
answer it and and if it's something that
dad that he gets a good feel
that'll be one of the first ones out of
the chute the next drive but and it's
also comforting it's also a comfort
level that he provides sitting next to
to him knowing that hey they're together
they're doing this thing together and
and it's good for both of them all right
now returning to the Bears when did you
first learn that it was real possibly
that Khalil Mack was coming to your team
so really it all happened pretty quick
we were going through the transition of
cutting down to our r53 and you know we
didn't know how real it was going to be
Ron and I we knew something could happen
during training camp but then really you
know that that uh that that Friday
Saturday Sunday weekend there was about
a 48 to 72 hour span there where we knew
that this okay this is real now we just
don't know how real and and so after
some some good conversations and just
you know being able to talk through it
and make it happen until then until that
facts agreement came through now that's
when we officially knew I said okay we
can finally you know saya have a fresh
of breath air and know that this thing
is officially real and so ever since
that's happened I mean we've been teased
what a what a you know we knew what we
were getting but for it's been another
level and and and it's just been he's
raised so many people's play on defense
and then just for everybody on the team
to see how how he works on and off the
field has been unbelievable well did you
get a note from Reed saying thanks for
taking him out of our division not him
not only not only coach but I also got
one from the GM from brevity she was the
first one I got he said I think is
exactly what was the the Chicago Bears
and the Kansas City Chiefs just got
better today it's amazing man I mean
really this guy is something else and
you were just plugging playing him and
he had an incredible game on that first
Sunday night I'm sure that was your
first big crucible as well as a coach
what did you say to your team after the
whole country was just fallen head over
heels over that comeback for Aaron
Rodgers at your expense that night yeah
that was a tough one rich that was one
for for our team for myself as a you
know first time to be through our team
to have a lead like that
that's a that's that's not an easy one
but you know I think that's going to be
one of those ones where we as a team
look back and as crazy as it sounds to
say I think it's going to help us down
the road and and you never like during
the time when that's going on you
obviously don't want to lose that game
but as long as we can be optimistic in
it and look at it glass half-full we'll
learn from that and we'll understand and
we've done that here the last couple
weeks where you know we've had different
types of wins in this three game win
streak that we've had where we've been
winning and we've kept the lead since
that Packers loss we've also won tower
we went to Arizona and we took two shots
right away and we're before you know
before you blink we're down 14 to
nothing and we fight and call back and
end up winning that game at the end of
the game and now we have one where we
get a nice we play all four quarters and
when from start to finish and so where
there's different ways that we're
winning and I think as long as we
understand that there's going to be some
scars and blemishes throughout this this
this path and how we build our character
that that's okay and so it's definitely
stung it hurt but it's so you know we're
gonna try to use it as a benefit down
the road well I mean I don't want to
make any problems for you though coach
as we depart I couldn't help but notice
you called your quarterback and his
first name
Mitch several times it doesn't you want
to be known as Mitchell well I think he
does and he goes back and forth now he's
got to be more consistent so he in when
we were before the draft and we were
with him it was the whole deal about his
mom said he needs to be called Mitchell
and it kind of went back and forth and
then he gets hell every now and then
he'll get frustrated and say well no
it's it's Mitch or I don't really care
just call whatever so I'll mix it up I
like to kind of one day it might be
Mitch the next day might be Mitchell the
next day might be tend you know so I
just go back and forth and I really
don't care what he thinks okay well then
if you don't mind me saying it's on you
I mean you got to get consistency out of
your quarterback I mean that's now on
you you know I mean it's all right does
anybody call you Matthew anybody you
know what they don't they don't I'm glad
they don't I like to stick by Matt okay
Matt thanks for the call really
appreciate it enjoy your bye week there
in Chicago a three and one and we'll
I've really enjoyed this chat and I hope
to do it again real soon absolutely rich
I appreciate it dig there right back
it's the head coach of the Chicago Bears
Matt nagging the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience